there are two things all that pointed
out about this question which is why I
selected it okay the first thing is you
notice on this polynomial
it's kind of been written in a bit of a
weird way in a strange way right
remember some of our language here right
which of these terms there are three
terms that restaurant which of these
terms is the most important term in this
polynomial on the liquid side the most
important term is the 3x cubed right in
fact at some point we give it that
special name starts with an L do you
remember it's called the leading term
it's got the degree attached to it the
leading term is usually hung at the
front like a leader usually is right so
this spine is actually being written
backwards okay
and this is kind of important to us we
need to write the polynomial in the
proper order in exactly the same way I
did if I said okay when you do five
thousand and you divide by seven right
you don't just put the numbers five zero
zero and zero in any order you write
like you're going to get something quite
different if you divide by this so the
order of the numbers is a lot a
significant and in the same way we're
gonna do that over here so I'm gonna
rewrite this first as equals and I'm
going to pop it in the right order
this is actually what I want okay but
the see second thing I wanna point out
is and now this is why I gave you this
example before see how we're dividing
five thousand by seven okay so there are
these zeros here okay as your is a funny
number like even the symbol itself most
conscious use a very similar symbol for
zero like it means it's a circle around
nothing right like that's actually what
consumed with it exactly the same way
that the signal division it means you've
got two things that you're literally
dividing them okay people didn't make me
make up these symbols just randomly okay
now be that there's nothing there when
there's nothing that we usually write
nothing for example you have a look at
this polynomial how many X terms are
there in the dividend it's up there
aren't any so we don't write them okay
that's that's pretty normal I there are
no X to the four zero or it's the five
so I just haven't written them okay but
as you can see when we went through this
process like you look back at your
working right these zeros are actually
critically important they form part of
my working like for starters I need a 5
and a zero in order to do the very first
division right so therefore even though
there isn't a zero X here I kind of need
to put it in in the same way that I have
the zeros here for my hundreds and tens
and units okay so I'm gonna rewrite one
more time with the missing terms in
there okay or there's only one in this
case I've got 3 X cubed minus X square
and I'm just going down and look at the
powers I'm making sure I don't miss any
ok so there's a 0x missing in here plus
11 and for however many terms that are
missing for instance if what I word
dividing were this 3x cubed plus 11
right I've got two terms missing in the
middle there the x squared and the X
right so I would rewrite that as 3x
cubed plus that many x squared and that
many X's and there's my eleven hanging
out on you okay
so wherever terms of missing you
actually have to include them in this
way that you include them in animal now
that I've written it like this now we're
ready to divide okay so let's just give
this a crack and now that we've gone
through this introductory example I'll
wonder if we can do this a little bit
click off so here we go I've got my X
plus suit my divisor at the front and he
comes the dividend right there we go how
do I begin
tell me what somebody hasn't sitting
here yet we've got any table just now
already my first step steady up 3x
squared what what is 3x squared it's how
many times X goes into this all right so
the 3x squared on here what do I do with
that multiply out the front so I get 3x
cubed plus 6x squared happy yeah ok do
the subtraction minus x squared take
away 6 x squared it's even morning so
negative 7 x squared and then big
winners but I've got this 0 X then that
comes down right so plus 0 X yep what I
do in this minus 7x squared yeah divided
by X how many X's do I fit man the
answer is minus 7x of them multiply back
down and that gives me this okay now
here's where the zero comes into play
right I do 0 and then I take away - 14 X
from 0 so what happens to that negative
is down it's a double negative so it
becomes positive so this is 0 plus 14x
so there you go ok so in some ways it
doesn't behave differently but it needs
to be there because otherwise you'd be
comparing like X terms with numbers and
that doesn't quite work out that's why
we go to these columns happening ok
almost finished
what Oh next I came an ad for tea
up there okay multiply it back one last
time 14x plus 28 what's my roommate up
negative 17 very good okay so there is
my answer okay and again just like I
have here I could rewrite this I could
say that be polynomial I started with at
the front 3x cubed minus x squared plus
11 it's equal to X plus 2 times that
takeaway 17 and finish this question in
some ways like because this is the focus
of this lesson
the real guts of the question is that we
simply do this this long division
process right so that's what we're
trying to master at the moment but if
you look carefully at the weight
question 3 is phrase they're asking a
subtly different question and in fact
question 3 is really good that this is a
last question in this set because that's
where the next sets are heading this is
kind of the more important question more
important than just can you divide can
you just tell me the answer
it's about KITT what can you do with
them okay so it says show you that 2x
minus 1 I just got a default divisor
because I'm trimming divided by that in
the second sure that 2x minus 1 is a
factor of this polynomial and express
that polynomial as a product okay so if
you think back to what we were doing
quadratics you remember quadratics it
was like a lot of effort was invested in
can you factorize this thing we learn
how to factorize by pairing well it had
a factorize by completing the square we
then had a factorize by quadratic
formula right factorizing it is it is a
really important problem because it
yields a lot inside so that's where
we're heading we want to get this thing
factorized in terms of this okay now in
fact because you guys are done
quadratics you can probably see what the
factors are a few sort of push it this a
little bit okay but when you've got
cubics or cording or quintics or
anything beyond power 2 then you really
need this division process net1 mastery
okay so let's do the division set up
I've got my dividend underneath the
division sign
okay here's my divisor over on the left
now what I want to point out to you
particularly this pod why I like this
question is that the divisor is no
longer monic right do you see I'm very
frequently been having something out
here where that leading coefficient is 1
so X must 2 or X minus 1 I love ah that
makes things easier out here I have a 2
now so I just need to take that into a
cards not any harder just keep this
extra process in your mind so how many
times does 2x going to 8x squared when I
divide this by this one I get the answer
is 4x right 4x I ignored that because
when I choose to multiply back I'm
supposed to get exactly the same thing
under here 4x times 2x is going to be 8x
squared okay if it's not the same then I
know what treasure the wrong thing to go
into my question oh I need to multiply
it by this as well so 4x times negative
1 is minus 4x okay and doing my
subtraction now okay I do 10 take away
negative 4 take away negative double
negative you don't wanna double
negatives happening here so this is
going to become 14x right for two new
tax then take away 7 comes for the
writing okay again it lasts my question
how many times does not X but 2x how
many times is 2x fit in here and the
answer is 7 times 7 times I multiply
back which gives me 7 times 2x is 14x 7
times negative 1 is negative 7 and I do
my subtraction I end up with 0 ok
because then you 7 take away that you 7
anything take away itself 0 so there's
my remainder
okay so I've proven it there you go if
it's a factor there's no remainder
that's what it means for something to be
a factor when I did this
ended up with a remainder hanging out
the enter 70s not a factor of 5,000 here
I do have a remainder zero so it's 2 X
minus 1 is a factor so let me rewrite
this right there for a x squared plus 10
X take away 7 is and the factorization
is just the product of those two guys
right 2x minus 1 4x plus 7 which you
could have worked out if you did the
quadratic formula or if you want you
thought about how to divide up this 10x
etc okay